[Music]
[Music]
if you've got a property that's 50,000
pounds the rent might be on a 50,000
pound house wish there some people from
London of same house what yes there are
lots of noise three-bedroom houses in
England that are 50 grand nice
oh yeah but they must be in the middle
of a red-light district and scumbags
live there it's all DSS
no nice people nice clean houses 50
grand three bedrooms they're on they
exist all over the place
how much rent would you get how much 250
400 I reckon for a 50 grand house you
could quite easily get in rent
about 450 let me ask you another
question so this is the value of the
house so this is the purchase value this
is the rental value if you've found a
property that wasn't 50 grand it is an
average nice house for 100 grand the
purchase values double does that mean
that the rental value is also double yes
or no no absolutely not you might be
talking Oh
maybe 550 and then 200 grand we know
already 850 so there's no direct
correlation between the house value and
the rental value make sense so in order
to get a higher return put in less get
more out it makes sense to buy houses
better cheaper yep
it's not rocket science so if you're
buying a house for two three hundred
grand unless you turn it into a big HMO
do something clever with it if it's a
single out property it's probably going
to give you a very low return now in
regards to areas I know we talked before
about big-picture prices go up and it
goes recession expansion recession
expansion recession expansion but
overall it goes up if we're looking at
areas of where to invest what's happened
in London over the last five seven years
massive expansion what's happening now
in London it's kind of static slash
going down even a little bit absolutely
but over the last five seven years so if
we are thinking short term or the IE
next five years and they tell let me
tell you a secret
everywhere follows London everywhere
follows London so London's now static
but guess what's happening here in
Birmingham at the moment yeah my house
is in this area I the Midlands have gone
up in value in the last six months by 10
percent that's good that's really good
six months some of my houses in Walsall
which is where we are right now I've got
a house I bought it in 2012 and I can
show you the right move history
everything like that I bought it in 2012
for 65 grand 2012 it's now worth 115
close to doubling in Birmingham and
that's going to continue for a while in
Birmingham but not for that long
why because everywhere follows London
little static Birmingham will get static
as well soon I think
Birmingham has got two years left of
growth and then it will fall static and
that's what I predict there's some parts
of the north where they're cheaper now
today than they were twelve years ago
I'll say that again there's areas in
this current
where the property prices are worth less
now than they were twelve years ago now
I don't know about you but I find that
pretty exciting because it's quite
obvious it doesn't take a rocket
scientist to work out that when you've
had 12 years of actual droppage and
nothing and when normally houses double
every 10 these areas are gonna boot true
or true of course they are because
they've wherever there's recession is
expansion and there's been such such bad
recession that they've actually dropped
in that's 12 years so inflation is going
up everything's gone up but these areas
stay down
why have they stayed down what's the
reasons well you reckon yeah kana me
what else
maybe unemployment I guess because
everywhere follows London London got hit
it's spreaded loulou's growing like
crazy these are still in the dark ages
Birmingham's caught up but this step the
rippling effect happens so so that's
what's happening so the cool thing at
the moment right now and the good thing
about these crash courses is I say every
time we do them it's different content
for two reasons reason number one
because there's different people with
different questions and you'll have a
lot of time to ask questions and things
like that it allocates Lots but but to
the markets changing so as things change
and different things come in the content
of what I teach you in the techniques
and strategies are different so right
now I am personally myself buying
properties cheap like this because I
know that they're going to go up
big-time
[Music]
you